[Música]
quando eu era pequena eu gostava de
brincar de se eu fosse se eu fosse se
brincar assim se eu fosse um carro que
cava seria se eu fosse um filme que
filme eu seria se fosse um bicho que
bicho seria e aí eu fiquei construindo a
minha vida em cima dessa brincadeira
então se fosse um filme eu seria cidadão
quem aquele sujeito que no fim da vida
diz a palavra rosman não sei se seria o
sujeito ou seria o jornalista que ficou
percorrendo essa história para construir
essa trama se eu fosse um bicho eu seria
um pingüim porque eu tive a chance de
mesmo vivendo em porto alegre tendo uma
infância aqui eu conheci um pinguim e
brinquei com ele como se ele fosse um
cachorro um gato e esse bichinho vivia
ali dentro daquele tanque e sempre me
dava uma sensação de inadequação eu
também fui uma criança que fiz coisas
que as outras crianças não faziam
pensava coisas que nem todo mundo
concordava mas se eu fosse um carro eu
seria uma kombi e uma kombi é um carro
que além de ser a gente poder levar até
uma escrivaninha dentro a gente pode
morar
a gente pode levar todos os amigos e
sair por aí
mas então juntando isso que será que uma
kombi um pinguim e o filme cidadão kane
têm em comum
e aí eu volto pro filme aquele sujeito
que no último instante larga aquela bola
e diz hosn bano me fez percorrer muitas
palavras durante a minha vida que
palavras me significariam que palavras
fariam sentido pra mim
qual seria a palavra que eu escolher lá
no último instante da minha vida e
durante a vida fui seguindo isso e de
novo chegou na palavra pinguim e enxergo
mais uma vez aquele pinguim dentro do
tanque
só que tem uma coisa eu contava essa
história e eu contava essa história pra
todo mundo já contei de jeito engraçado
já contei de jeito e dramático já contei
de várias maneiras só que nunca ninguém
acreditou
assim ninguém acreditando a gente pára
de contar só que parar de contar é um
jeito de esquecer o que aconteceu comigo
eu tive a sorte de um dia tá num estádio
de futebol lotado enxergar o sujeito que
era dona da casa que era dono do tanque
do pinguim e disse para o meu marido
para os meus filhos olha aquele ali
também sabe da história do pinguim o meu
filho era criança e foi até ele
quando ele chegou pertinho eu fiquei com
muito medo daquela história não ser
verdade
imagina se não fosse fosse tudo miami se
fosse 11 um bicho imaginário meu amigo
imaginário meu coelho da páscoa bom mas
não quando meu filho virou com sorriso
aqui eu disse meu deus
a história do pingüim é verdadeira e com
ela minha infância toda a realidade da
minha infância estava recuperada ali
naquele minutinhos no minutinhos em que
eu tive apoio a positividade do domínio
do doping gay que acontece então eu não
autorizei a ser escritora e aí eu
comecei a escrever muitas histórias a
primeira história que eu escrevi era um
quadro que tinha meninas dentro
a segunda história que eu escrevi era
uma menina que vivia dentro de uma caixa
a terceira história que eu escrevi era
um menino que vivia dentro de um muro e
não tinha como sair ea quarta história
uma vaca que estava numa cena que não
conseguia sair
tinha um negócio estranho aí aí o que
aconteceu eu comecei a conversar com os
leitores e os leitores vão me dizendo
esmola
está todo mundo meio trancado mas o que
me pareceu legal nisso é que a interação
que se dava com o leitor cada leitor
quando pegava aquele texto colocava sua
história ali não se conformava com isso
e essa interação que eu vivi como
escritora eu me dei conta que eu também
vivia como leitora então toda vez que eu
me colocava diante de um livro novo eu
estava reescrevendo aquele livro e eu
queria que os meus leitores também
fizessem isso também restringe
e daí eu escolhi uma nova palavra pra
mim acompanhar é interação essa palavra
interação que eu acho que a leitura
visceral a leitura bacana a leitura que
promove essa interação
só que eu queria libertar os outros e
comecei sempre estudar a história de
outras pessoas e aí eu experimentei uma
outra palavra que a palavra empatia a
palavra empatia ela me ajudou a conhecer
a história de outras pessoas e assim eu
escrevi uma história sobre o iberê
camargo outra história sobre a clara
pechansky outra sobre o noel rosa e
assim eu fui construindo mais e mais
livros tentando libertá los
os libertar os personagens dessas
histórias acontece que eu chegava nos
eventos e percebia que faltava uma coisa
e esse sentimento de interação e de
empatia que eu tinha que eu queria
promover para os meus leitores
eu não tava percebendo naquele leitor
ali eu via muitos eventos muita festa e
pouca leitura ea leitura interna ela
toca no botãozinho e aí que eu fiz eu
tive que voltar a estudar entrar de novo
na aventura de estudar e nessa aventura
ao descobrir que o ler e o brincar fazem
parte do mesmo lugar nos ocupam do mesmo
jeito e se alguém não quer fazer nada há
de querer brincar e querendo brincar
disso mas como assim brincar que quer
brincar e o que o que eu percebo que
brincar é um aprendizado
a gente pode ter uma sociedade onde não
se brinca é só tirar o espaço o tempo ea
possibilidade para isso isso pra mim foi
arrasador
a gente pode sim construir uma sociedade
onde não se brinque e se não se brinca
não se acessa mais o botão da arte gente
aí eu comecei a entrar nesse estudo do
brinquedo e cheguei numa brincadeira que
é essa aqui é uma brincadeira que todo
mundo conhece
não tem quem não tenha jogado não
tem quem cuide se conheça as regras não
tem quem saiba quem ensinou
não tem quem saiba quem disse as regras
pela primeira vez e ninguém nunca mais
esqueceu é uma brincadeira bacana porque
não interessa se quem ganha ou não ganha
a gente vai brincando por brincam não
gostei de perder nem de mim e aí o e
essa brincadeira ela dá uma sensação de
que alguém sabe antes da gente então ela
nos conecta ancestralmente ela nos dá
essa concepção que é anterior a mim a
minha existência
antes de mim se brincou disso e essa
sensação de ancestralidade me coloca no
lugar que é seu sei de onde eu vim
talvez eu possa ter mais facilidade para
descobrir para onde eu vou
mas outra coisa que ela me daqui é muito
bacana é a muitas pessoas em lugares
diferentes que eu não sei de onde vieram
que eu não sei que línguas falam muitas
pessoas sabem a mesma regra e isso me
torna própria de um grupo
ela me dá essa se esse sentimento de
pertencimento então se uma brincadeira
simples me dá a idéia de ancestralidade
e de pertencimento o brincar é muito
poderoso
o brincar não é uma brincadeira o
brincar a gente pode se incluir na nossa
vida e tem mais uma coisa que eu
descobri o que é um objecto de brincar
existe brinquedo
quantas vezes a gente já entregou um
brinquedo por uma criança ela brincou
com a caixa
ela brinca com a caixa sabe porquê
porque o brinquedo tem três eixos
o brinquedo é pensar fazer e agir quando
eu dou um brinquedo pronto para qualquer
pessoa eu abri e viu duas etapas
ela só vai agir sobre aquilo e na caixa
ela vai poder pensar sobre o que ela
quer fazer fazer efetivamente depois
brincar com aquilo que ela fez
e pensou e aí eu penso em objetos do
brincar um objeto que serve pra amarrar
ele também serve para outras coisas e
assim eu vou construindo brincar e
brinquedos no qq no que quiser
só que além disso eu tenho que parar
aqui porque o brinquedo é sempre um
encontro quando se brinca se está
conectado com o passado se está
conectado com o que eu fui o que eu
quero ser
mas também se passe conectado com o
encontro se não é um encontro comigo
mesmo
é um encontro com o outro e aí aconteceu
uma outra coisa que eu ia fazer agora eu
era escritora eu tinha toda essa
concepção
mas o que aconteceu eu gostava de kombi
do que eu fiz
peguei uma kombi que é onde entravam
todos os meus amigos dentro dessa como
eu chamei a zizi que é uma grande
oficina de arte
eu chamei o maurício que é um grande
brincadeira e chamei o luiz é o nosso
motorista em juntos a gente criou ilhas
de criação
as ilhas de criação são assim a gente
coloca um objetos de circo
nesses objetos de circo quem faz a
mágica quem vem para brincar a gente
colocou livros únicos são livros
escritos à mão a gente chamou escritores
que têm vida literária mas ali eles
escrevem à mão são livros para ler não é
livre pra comprar não é livre para levar
o livro para sentar e ler usufruir da
leitura
a gente tem um espaço que é um de um
livro interativo em vez de páginas eles
são painéis grandões onde a gente pode
ler olhar e brincar é possível se
fantasiar com a roupa do personagem é
possível montar o cenário é possível
escrever outras histórias ea gente tem
uma ilha de cultura popular
são brinquedos porque a cultura popular
é uma chance de a gente viveu uma
infância de novo a gente sempre viveu
uma nova infância então tem uma ilha de
cultura popular
filha de instrumentos musicais e uma
ilha onde pode se fazer arte que tem um
museu com quadros e um museu
o quadro que comumente estão dentro de
um dom do museu mas que tem quanto tempo
a arte popular arte de rua é tem grafite
também e nesse espaço também é possível
produzir arte então saímos por aí
seguimos o nosso momento montamos a
nossa ilha e mas aí eu fui perguntar
para o mastro longa será isso mesmo que
eu devia fazer e da sogra assim olha tem
que achar um lugar não lugar de glória
um lugar não lugar isso vai andar por aí
tu vai saber o que é
e aí eu me encontro com uma menina que
se chama luiza acho ke ha luis achou que
era formanda de artes e ela me
apresentou um projeto projeto de
formatura dela era um cubo
só que eu trouxe um pequeno pra mostrar
ela fez um cubo de três metros
esse cubo é ela deixou em alguns lugares
na cidade de são paulo e as pessoas
interagirão com esse currículo esse cubo
eu disse tá aí o lugar num lugar a
astróloga tinha razão que eu fiz essa
esse cubo agente reproduziu e coloca nos
espaços cada vez que a gente chega e faz
ocupa aquele cubo já foi platéia aquele
cuja foi teatro aquele cuja foi
biblioteca aquele cubo serve para ser o
que a gente quer é ser é o nosso vazio
o vazio da existência mas também o vazio
das possibilidades né é essa falta que
vai acabar nos levando para um outro
lugar
e aí o que aconteceu teve uma vez que a
gente chegou numa comunidade era uma
comunidade muito vulnerável era uma
comunidade com muitas carências e nessa
comunidade
a gente perguntou o que vocês querem e
já preparados para fazer campanha de
alimento pra fazer campanha de de de
roupa de alguma necessidade que eles
tinham ou médicos ou medicamento não
aquela comunidade dos dias
o que a gente quer mesmo é cantar
e aí a gente entendeu que o papel da
arte não é brincadeira e que a gente
pode sim libertar aquele pinguim em
porque aquele pinguim ele pode ele tem
um oceano inteiro para viver e esse
botãozinho vai ser acionado pelo brincar
e pela arte
a gente não pode mais brincar com
cidadão kane
ele se deu tarde demais conta que o que
a memória que ele tinha era o o o trenó
ninho dele mas a gente pode sair por aí
brincando e lembrando ferreira gullar a
arte existe porque a vida não basta
obrigada
[Aplausos]